this is a CNN reporter at the Capitol in
the last couple days in the fall out of
this talking to Byron Donalds from
Florida and representative Andy oogles
from Tennessee about uh guns so Second
Amendment here in the United States
people are allowed to possess Firearms
need is in the eye of the beholder
I don't question why you need a blue
suit but you got one and I know we're
talking about something very very
different but the second amendment
allows American citizens to possess
Firearms the why not limit the to the
AR-15s why not run up with a ban on that
if you're going to talk about the AR-15
you're talking politics now let's not
get into politics
all right let's not get into emotion
because emotion feels good but emotion
doesn't solve problems why not ban
AR-15s
why not talk about the real issue facing
this country in regards to the shooting
which would be Mental Health
you know when we talk about these
quote-unquote journalists to me that is
such a perfect example of it because
it's subtle what they do it's not that
he's going out there yelling at the guy
but the way he asked the question so
there's a shooting and immediately the
question should be why don't we do
something against the Second Amendment
so it's it's a trickery in how they're
actually going about the business right
Ashley
yeah that's a classic uh way of what in
in the study of bias is called framing
you frame it right off the bat as as
having to do with guns the questions are
about guns in the answers even in the
negative therefore are about guns so you
just get people saying guns guns guns
guns guns over and over and over and
that also brings in another kind of bias
which is omission bias what is not being
spoken about here and that is a whole
host of other factors and things that
are at play that are all crowded out for
this one three letter word and again uh
let's talk about it sure talk about guns
but you cannot have that conversation at
the exclusion of every single other
factor that might be involved that is
absurd that is exactly what the
gentleman was saying that is politics
that is not journalism
Josh I I don't like playing the games
that the left plays with you know always
blaming a group of people for the
actions of one individual but at what
point if we have an entire mainstream
media that is constantly going after you
know white straight Christians as the
worst people on the planet who have ever
existed
at what point are they somewhat culpable
and I know that is an extremely slippery
slope but but the constant demon is it
there's one group you're allowed to
demonize and that's the group of people
that happen to be killed in this uh
incident
look from where I'm sitting you know Jew
hatred and anti-christian bigotry are
probably the last two politically
correct forms of bigotry in the United
States today I mean it is not merely not
a problem to criticize Jews and
Christians when they're acting like Jews
and Christians but it is often times it
is praise I mean that will get you
platformed by large swaths of the
liberal media I don't think that's
overstating it and you know I like you I
I tend to try to stick to individual
culpability individuals are responsible
for their actions and all of that there
but the the media as a class has just
such dripping animus and disdain for the
traditional views of religious Jews
religious Christians frankly even just
like you know religious Muslims as well
honestly too and to an extent I think
back to this op-ed that there's only
tangentially related I think back to
this op-ed the New York Times published
a couple weeks ago it was basically
saying that oh the Jews but back at the
time the Torah was given in Sinai oh of
course they supported transgenderism and
like I like are you kidding me I I I
mean like what is wrong with you people
if you'd like more sane takes on our
insane World check out our direct
message clips playlist and if you want
to watch more full episodes of our live
roundtables watch our round tables
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell